republicans are ripping into president
biden for doing
nothing to stop the border surge
not a thing so migrants are streaming in
like crazy total crossings are at a
20-year high
and a record number of unaccompanied
minors were picked up by border patrol
republicans are finally asking and
saying enough is enough take a look
the biden administration has been
anti-wall
and awol how could president biden and
kamala harris
allow this to go on and not even come
here and see it for themselves
this is a humanitarian crisis and i
i can't even in good conscience call
president biden
president i have to call him trafficker
in chief
and texas governor greg abbott is
demanding that biden administration
investigate allegations of child abuse
at a border facility
these horrific images and tragic deaths
as well as assaults that we're seeing
right now they would not be happening if
the by demonstration had not opened up
the border
and been completely unprepared for the
massive influx of
the young migrant children that they are
enticing
to come across the border and we're just
learning biden's borders are
stepping down as the crisis grows so
ronald i want to come to you first um
we have allegations of uh joe biden
uh you know being a guy who's out of
control at the border
we have little kids who are you know
raped and abused on the way
north we have kids dying in the desert
kids dying in the rio grande
now there's allegations in a border
facility that
you know little kids are being sexually
assaulted
isn't this policy heartless from joe
biden
i have to first say sean that that
florida congresswoman who's new to the
job
calling the president of the united
states the human trafficker in chief is
brow it's low down and dirty it's
disgusting i mean how dare she
uh to accuse him of uh child rape and
uh supporting and collaborating and
this hideous crimes i mean it's
absolutely horrible
joe biden is guilty of naivete and
incompetence
we have to restart the wall right now it
should be part of a big deal with the
democrats
where the dreamers get a pathway to
citizenship and the wall
restarts but to call the president of
the united states
this despicable uh you know a slur
is is beyond uh is beyond the pale i
mean
is this where we are now in politics in
america
where you can call the president of the
united states
uh complicit in child rape i mean it's
uh it's
that's to me it's almost impeachable
it's it's not protected by the first
amendment this congresswoman
went way over the cliff but but what
come geraldo
we just had four years of the other side
labeling republicans nazis and comparing
trump to hitler almost
every other hour this is nothing
compared to what
anybody on the right has endured i agree
with you though it doesn't
help the conversation but to act
outraged over this you must have been
asleep for four years and i know you
weren't cause you were on this show
geraldo i
saw you here so you so i was
sleepwalking yes
and i think i think he might even call
me a couple of names
but can i since i'm already talking i
just saw something like that
i just saw that like biden is
considering sending cash to central
america
uh to kind of persuade people not to
come to like guatemala honduras and el
salvador
giving them money paying them not to
come so
it's kind of a win-win if you come here
you're going to get free services
but if you stay home you're going to get
paid so that's a
i mean can they do this to me like like
if i decide if i say on this show that i
want to go to canada
i know canada wouldn't want that would
they pay me to stay
in the united states yeah i know jillian
they would not let me come
i just checked i just checked they don't
want you sorry
i'm sorry to be the one to tell you so
how much are they going to pay me
500 bucks i'm texting canada right now
we'll get you an answer
but julia i want to respond to geraldo i
mean i do think a lot of americans a lot
of republicans look at the policy that
has
allowed so many migrants to come to our
border and as biden's policy
and these kids are being sex trafficked
and sold into
indentured servitude why shouldn't that
fall at the feet of
of joe biden well the big story now
sean especially if what governor greg
abbott has told us is true which is that
more than one child has been sexually
assaulted
while in u.s border care is that the big
story is now
the fact that the u.s government writ
large is failing dismally
at its duty to protect foreign children
that it takes into its custody
they have a legal obligation to ensure
that these children are
number one safe and protected from
predators and number two to ensure
that they're healthy and that they're
not unnecessarily subjected to
communicable diseases while they're in
us custody we know that at some of these
facilities at the border
covid transmission rates are 15 so i
think the story now becomes
not so much i mean look assigning blame
is always an important
part of policy and politics but the
story now is not so much
who exactly but acknowledgement that
we've got this
epic problem on our hands and that the
u.s government is failing
writ large and and it a success would be
making sure kids stay home with their
parents in these northern triangle
countries instead of going on this
horrific journey but katy i want to come
to you because
the amount of money that we're going to
pay to house
migrant children is 3.1 billion dollars
that's four times the amount we spend
through the small business
administration
to actually help small businesses
recover from
covet this is insane isn't it
the money isn't saying the cons
consequences are insane but i want to
respond to
geraldo if we're going to solve this
problem you have to deal
in reality of what's going on and you
can put politics aside but there are
consequences for joe biden's policy
positions
on the border i'm in arizona i was out
with the pinal county sheriff's
department yesterday looking at
smuggling
routes looking at what they're leaving
behind hearing what they're talking
about and it is now
more lucrative for drug cartels in
mexico
to be trafficking human beings than it
is for them to be trafficking drugs this
is no longer about
enabling people to come to america for a
better way of life this is about
enabling a multi-billion dollar
trafficking industry
and smuggling industry where human
beings are a commodity that are worth
more money
than smuggling drugs and on the issue of
the accusation that joe biden is
complicit in the trafficking
he is these policies we know for years
open border policies enable trafficking
they enable smuggling and the federal
government is allowing
people in these these northern triangle
countries to take their child
give them to a smuggler that's one step
the smuggler then takes the child to the
border second step
and then dhs takes that child and
delivers them to wherever
their phone number is or to a sponsor
family that hasn't necessarily been
fully vetted
so they're completing the smuggling ring
on behalf of this billion dollar
industry those are the facts a lot of
what happens on the on the border is not
easy to stomach but if we're going to
solve this problem we can't act like
it's not happening and that's the
reality of what's happening on the
ground
yeah that's
destroying your own intellectual
argument because that's all you focus on
it's ridiculous no one said he was a
trafficker
we're saying his policies enable
trafficking and smuggling which is a
fact if you talk to anybody who's
involved in what's going on here
including the trafficking you can stop
the trafficking on day on day two if you
would just implement donald trump's
policies on the border this would be
over if you cared about kids but
great discussion guys uh up next is the
fastest